sure if space goes on forever it might
just be really really big in which case
there's a point I know my parallel
universes but the inflation predicts
that piccoli that it goes on forever
the simplest space we all were taught in
school and a Euclid's space also goes on
forever
it gets more even more interesting with
this inflation theory because it turns
out it makes almost like the fractal
space where whether these boundaries
where inflation never stops and these
everything within an expanding boundary
is caught there's a level one multiverse
and then there are many of them in level
two multiverse and this is such a
violent process that the different parts
of space that are made can actually if
physics if space can be in many
different states kind of like water can
be in different states you know ice
steam liquid you know with different
properties if space could be like that
to which string theory suggests and
inflation is gonna make all these
different kinds of space that's level
two multiverse so there might be
somewhere far far away where people
learn in school that actually prepare
the periodic table has only five kinds
of atoms or a hundred and eighty kinds
of atoms and so on so here in our
universe the physics would be taught the
same across the planets but the history
is taught differently of how the
civilization evolved but in an
alternative part of a the next level of
a different place in the multiverse that
physics could in fact be different right
because not not because physics is truly
different that still may be on rule by
string theory but a lot of things that
we thought were fundamental weren't it's
like if you were fish and you would
spend your whole life in the ocean you
might think it was a law of physics that
water is always a liquid just because
you've never seen an iceberg yeah and
you would learn that water has this kind
of viscosity and this kind of Sound
speed which is not true if if you're
inside of an iceberg or extreme cloud
and then the third level just that just
adds more humility we've discovered
basically it's super hard to have any
theory of physics that just and makes
the stuff that we can actually see and
observe and nothing more I gave you two
examples the quantum physics the theory
of they're very small has that same
property we've discovered that when we
look really closely at the electrons and
these other elementary particles that
make up us they can be in multiple
places at once but we are made of them
so that means we should be able to be in
many places at once
and this guy you Everett he worked that
out and fifties and showed that the
quantum mechanics is just true with no
ifs and buts there's this morning
equation the Schrodinger equation and
that's it then as you were saying
earlier as as if our life kind of Forks
out there are many times when we make a
decision snap decision you know should
we ask this person on a date or not
where it might come down to just whether
one neuron fired or not in the beginning
triggering a whole cascade of events
could end up with you living in this
city you know they married to this
person with children or living somewhere
completely different doing something
different yeah and now that neuron
firing might in turn have been
determined just by the position of one
little atom in your brain so if that
Adam was in two places at once
eventually you're living in two
different cities and so this kind of
branching and amplification of weirdness
from the micro world where a little atom
is in two places at once into the macro
world is what leads to this so-called
many-worlds interpretation of the level
3 multiverse if that's actually the way
things are
yeah then every time you get a parking
ticket you can chill out and take solace
in the fact that there was probably
apparently universe you know where you
didn't it kind of takes the pressure off
a little